Metaphorically it takes blood and guts to
perform certain roles in blockbuster films
but sometimes that blood and guts are actually
required.
Some of your favorite actors in some awesome
films have hurt themselves on set but like
true performers they finished their roles.
The show must go on as they say, despite these
injuries even if they were life-threatening.
When we talk about your favorite stars make
sure to like and comment on this video and
subscribe to join the notification squad for
cool content like this daily.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Actors
Who Took it Too Far on Set.
Tom Holland in Captain America: Civil War
Before Tom Holland showed up on screen in
Captain America: Civil War there was of course
naysayers about his casting as Spider-Man.
Anytime someone is helmed to play a role there
is a group of fans that complain and Holland
was not safe from this.
Before a trailer even came out Holand talked
about an on set stumble that gave him bruises
and gashes across his face.
Sadly, this wasn’t because of an elaborate
stunt but because of his coordination and
this sparked rumors that he wasn’t qualified
to be Spider-Man.
Luckily he proved all those pessimists wrong
and was a great addiction to Civil War.
The Cast in Suicide Squad
Director David Ayer saw numerous blunders
on set of Suicide Squad from his cast during
production.
Star Will Smith tore his calf right out the
gate forcing him to be out for 6 weeks than
a few days later Joel Kinnaman, who played
Rick Flag blew out his calf.
Kinnaman joked that he did it out of sympathy
for Smith but no one had it as bad as Margot
Robbie.
She did the same stunts as the men but in
high heels and in much less clothing, we mean
padding.
At one point she thought she broke her ribs
but she actually just pulled her muscle off
her ribs and that made her stunts painful
for the rest of filming but didn’t stop
her from stealing the show.
Here is a trivia question for you, did Margot
Robbie learn to hold her breath, fist fight
or sword fight for her role of Harley Quinn?
The answer will be at the end of our video.
Brad Pitt in Se7en
Brad Pitt worked himself to the bone in the
1994 film Se7ev, literally.
When Detective David Mills chases the killer
through a rainy street he slipped and his
arm went through a windshield.
The glass cut his arm so deep that it severed
a tendon and went down to the bone.
His injury was so severe he had to wear a
cast for the rest of the film so they had
to write his injury into the script, rather
than halt production for numerous months.
At least he didn’t lose his head.
Robert Downey Jr. in Iron Man 3
At the time of Iron Man 3’s production Robert
Downey Jr. was 47 years old and while portraying
the comic book hero in Marvel's blockbuster
movie franchise he wounded himself.
While performing a stunt the actor twisted
his ankle causing him to be out of work for
5 weeks, which is very costly to productions.
Don’t even try to tell us RDJ is too old
to be performing stunts because since then
he has clashed with Ultron and Captain America
keeping his own; not to mention he looked
awesome doing it.
Elsa Fisher in Now You See Me
When you are using a chainsaw to cut a woman
in half there is always a chance of a mistake
happening and some magicians will claim a
water tank act is even more dangerous.
Elsa Fisher might be one of those that believes
a water tank can become a coffin because she
almost died in one on the set of Now You See
Me.
During a take she was supposed to escape chains
and free herself from a tank but she got tangled
and almost drowned.
She signaled for help but they thought she
was acting and didn’t come to her aid, luckily
she freed herself and went on to act another
day.
Ben Affleck in Batman V Superman: Dawn of
Justice
Ben Affleck has desired to be a superhero
mega star for a long time, that’s why he
took the role of Daredevil and gave it his
all in Batman V Superman: Dawn of Justice.
While shooting the film, the Batman actor
hurt his shoulder so bad that his stunt double
had to perform minor lifting scenes for the
star.
Affleck was used to playing characters with
minor physical requirements before this role
and the speed he prepared for this role might
have been too fast.
We can’t wait to see him kick some butt
in the next Batman film he’s involved with,
hopefully injury free.
Here is your next trivia question, fill in
the blank.
Ben Affleck directed the 2007 film blank Baby
blank.
The answer is coming up soon.
Halle Berry in Gothika
Robert Downey Jr. has been known as a prolific
actor for a long time to fans and the film
industry alike.
His role as Chaplin garnered him a much deserved
Academy Award nomination and today he wows
us with his performance as Iron Man in the
marvel films.
He gets so into his roles that he sometimes
forgets himself and during a scene with Halle
Berry in Gothika he accidentally hurt the
actress.
The scene is when he had to restrain Berry
and hold her arms down, as he held her down
he broke her arm.
The moment RDJ heard the pop, he stopped and
she was treated, they are still friends today
and she holds nothing against him.
Channing Tatum in Foxcatcher
Channing Tatum wanted to show his acting chops
with 2014’s Foxcatcher.
In the scene where his character has a breakdown
in a hotel room, he breaks a mirror with his
head but despite precautions he still got
hurt.
The mirror had a plastic sleeve attached to
it to protect Tatum but the actor went too
far and bashed his head three times into the
mirror.
He broke the mirror, the frame and the wall
behind the mirror, not to mention he cut his
head too.
You can actually see his blood in the movie,
no makeup artist was needed.
Vin Diesel in Fast and Furious 7
Fist fights with Jason Stratham, beatings
with lead pipes, being slammed against cars
and minor concussions sounds like a typical
day on set of the Fast and Furious franchise.
Especially if you are the star and producer
of these films, Vin Diesel.
During production of Fast and Furious 7, Diesel
hurt himself and was rushed to the hospital
because of a concussion.
He doesn’t know how he got the concussion
because the day he did receive it he was performing
numerous stunts.
We’re betting Michele Rodriguez got upset
with him and showed him why she’s one of
the coolest female action stars around.
Here is your last trivia question that we’ll
be giving you the answer soon.
Which Steven Spielberg war film was Vin Diesel
in?
The Rock in Central Intelligence
Two guys that love social media as much as
social media loves them is Dwayne Johnson
and Kevin Hart, so when they were making their
film Central Intelligence Johnson decided
to hoax his audience.
He showed how even a broken finger can’t
make him shed a tear with an Instagram video
but it’s easy not to shed a tear when you’re
using a prosthetic finger.
The actor was fine but we bet he wished he
was using a prosthetic head when Hart slams
a door shut and a tile crashed down on his
head.
He’s lucky the pointy side of the tile didn’t
get him and Hart is lucky The Rock has a sense
of humor because he laughed at the body-builders
misfortune.
There you have it ten Actors Who Took it Too
Far on Set.
Here are the answers to our trivia questions:
Margot Robbie learn to hold her breath for
her role of Harley Quinn.
Ben Affleck directed the 2007 film Gone Baby
Gone.
Steven Spielberg casted Vin Diesel in Saving
Private Ryan.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos like this every day and
thanks for watching.